SPEAKER: We have
Olivia and Judah here.
Olivia wrote the New
York Times best selling
book called "Charisma Myth."
If you haven't read
it, it's amazing.
And Judah works for Berkeley's
Haas Business School,
and also works at
[? Stardex. ?] And they recently
wrote a book called "The
Net and the Butterfly"
to help you work on
your creative process.
So without any further ado,
let's welcome them to Google.
[APPLAUSE]
JUDAH POLLACK: Thank you.
So when we started doing
research for this book,
we came upon this
really wild pattern.
And so-- this is Leo Szilard.
He went to a lecture in the
late '30s about nuclear physics,
and as he was walking
across the street,
literally in mid-stride,
he had this realization
about how he could
start a nuclear chain
reaction using fission.
Then we get Henri Poincare--
how'd I do, how'd I do?
Henri Poincare.
Olivia's native French
speaker, so every time
I come upon a French
word, it's a nightmare.
OLIVIA FOX CABANE: It kills me.
JUDAH POLLACK:
So, he was working
on an incredibly difficult
series of math functions,
and one morning as he
was getting on a bus
to go to a conference--
he remembers this very
distinctly-- he put his foot
on the step, the first step
of the bus, and
suddenly, it came to him.
He knew what his answer was.
So then we come to
Nikola Tesla, who
was trying to work on a
functioning alternating
current generator.
He's walking through a
park with his friends
when suddenly, he
realizes exactly how he's
going to do it.
He needs one of the
engines to rotate
in the opposite direction
from the other two
that are going to be
part of the generator.
This also brings
us to Heisenber--
Heisenberg, sorry.
For those of you who are fans--
if you type-- if you now type
Heisenberg into the Google
search engine,
that's what you get.
He has now eclipsed Werner.
Walter has eclipsed Werner.
Werner Heisenberg
has a conversation
with Niels Bohr in
Copenhagen, late night,
walking through a
park, what happens?
He's like, can the
universe really
be as strange as I think it is?
He comes up with the
uncertainty principle.
This just keeps happening.
Godel and Einstein,
famous for taking
walks together in
Princeton at the Institute
for Advanced Study.
Darwin had something
called the sand walk.
What he would do is he would
start at the corner there,
and he'd put a couple of
stones, he'd stack them.
And he'd walk the
sand walk while he
thought about the
problem, and he'd
knock a stone off every lap.
And he knew, he's like, this
is a three stone problem,
this is a six stone problem.
But he would walk his
way to the answer.
Same thing with Tchaikovsky,
three hour walks,
every afternoon.
And then we get
Emmanuel Kant, who
it is said you could set
your watch by his walks
because he'd walk
around the town square
the same time every day.
You keep going back in
history, it keeps showing up.
Aristotle, who founded
a school, and they
were known as the peripatetics.
Why?
Because they walked around
as they philosophized.
And then, of course, we had
the famous story of Archimedes
who's stepping into the tub,
watches the water displacement,
and suddenly
realizes, this is how
I'm going to figure out if the
crown is solid gold or not,
by checking its density.
Something very
strange is going on,
but this story keeps
happening over and over,
and it's not just with walking.
It happens with sleep.
So this is Dmitri Mendeleev
who spent three years working
on a chemistry textbook, driven
crazy that he couldn't put it
into more order.
And during a
feverish nap, woke up
with a picture of
this in his head.
Wrote it down as
fast as he could.
Who's in there?
Oh, you're going
to hate me again.
August-- are you going
to make me do it?
OLIVIA FOX CABANE: Go.
JUDAH POLLACK: Kekule?
How'd I do?
No?
Nightmare.
OLIVIA FOX CABANE:
That's fine, go ahead.
JUDAH POLLACK: We're moving on.
So, chemist, German
chemist, 1800s.
Everybody's trying to figure
out the shape of benzene
at the time.
Nobody can do it.
He has a dream of a snake
eating its own tail,
and suddenly realizes
that benzene is a ring.
This literally creates
structural organic chemistry,
which creates the tar
and dye industries,
it creates the
pharmaceutical industries.
You ever wondered why so many
pharmaceutical companies are
German, it's because
he was German
and started his
first lab in Bonn.
Ramanujan, famous numbers
theorist from India.
Used to say that the goddess
would write the equations
on his tongue in his
dreams, and so he'd
wake up with stuff like this.
Finally, Salvador Dali.
Now, he knew exactly what
he was doing with sleep.
He would sit down in a
straight backed chair,
and he would hang his arm over
the side holding a metal key
with a metal plate underneath.
And as he dozed off,
he would drop the key,
and the key would hit
the plate, make a rattle,
wake him up, and as soon as he
woke up, he'd start drawing.
And we all know what those
drawings ended up looking like.
So here we have all
of these geniuses who
are accessing walking and
sleeping in different ways
to come up with these
amazing breakthroughs.
What is it that
they figured out?
What did they know?
And as another example,
I want to tell you
that when I was
showering this morning,
thinking about this
stuff, coming here,
I suddenly realized I
wanted to show you all this.
[CHEERING AND YELLING ON VIDEO]
I'm going to come back to that.
I'm going to tell you why I want
to show you that in a minute.
It's not just because it's
really funny, which it is.
We have the capacity
to know so much.
When we look up at
the stars, we're
amazed at how many
stars there are.
We're amazed at the sheer
immensity of the universe
and our place in it.
But the reality is that
when we look up at the sky,
that's how much we're
actually seeing.
We are not truly aware
of how much is out there.
We're not truly aware how
much more we could see,
and the same is true of how
we access our own brains.
We are not aware
of just how much
we have the capacity to do.
And what we wrote about in this
book is not only what is this
physical mechanism inside
everyone's brains--
and I want to be
clear, it's everyone's.
It's not just geniuses.
The geniuses have the same
exact physical structures
in their brain that
every one of you has.
But it's a question
of accessing it.
It's a question of trusting it.
And so what we're
going to do is we're
going to talk a lot about
tools, because the thing
about breakthroughs,
creativity, innovation
is there are a lot of theories.
And people lay out theories all
the time, but this is a craft.
This is like an artisan's craft.
And just like artisans,
there are tools,
and you have to practice
with those tools
in order to gain mastery.
And that's really what we
were interested in this book.
So to explain what the
process is in your brain,
we made a short animation
that we want to show you.
And the story we're going
to tell you is true.
And everything going on
inside the brain is also true.
JUDAH POLLACK (ON
VIDEO): Florida, 1965.
The Rolling Stones are
on their first US tour,
but they're not the
Rolling Stones yet.
They're about as popular
as Herman's Hermits.
What they're in need of is a
breakthrough hit, a number one
song, and no one knows it
more than Keith Richards.
One night in his
motel room, Richards
was trying to write that song.
So what's going on
inside his brain
while he's attempting to
have this breakthrough?
This is the executive of
Keith Richards's brain.
It's focused, on task, and
has a goal; write a hit song.
There's just one problem, it's
not very good at breakthroughs
by itself.
See, the executive
network is great
when you need to make a
list or complete a project,
but when it comes to
having a breakthrough,
it needs some help.
That night, Richards
fell asleep.
And no longer on
task, his executive
went to talk to another network
that lies deeper in the brain.
Now what we're about
to show you is not
unique to Keith Richards.
You have the same exact
room in your brain.
We all do, we just
don't access it enough.
This is your genius lounge.
About 10 different
brain regions in here,
all hanging out, talking.
There's Mozart, Leonardo da
Vinci, Marie Curie, Einstein.
Welcome to the
part of your brain
that's working on
stuff when you don't
think you're working on stuff.
That night, Richards's executive
walked in and said, "Quiet!
All right, everyone, we
need to breakthrough hit.
Now go."
The executive went and busied
itself with something mindless,
in this case,
sleep, but it can be
doing the dishes or the
laundry or taking a shower.
Meanwhile, the geniuses
started sharing
all kinds of information
from art to music
to childhood memories.
This was the sum total of
Keith Richards' experience
and knowledge,
and that combining
created his intuition.
It created a breakthrough.
Richards woke up in the middle
of the night and began to play.
[GUITAR MUSIC]
That was how the Rolling Stones
got their breakthrough hit
"Satisfaction."
But it is not just
Keith Richards.
We all have an executive and
a genius lounge in our brains.
The key to having
more breakthroughs
is learning how to switch
between the two modes.
JUDAH POLLACK: All right.
That was me doing
the voice work,
and I'm going to pick that
up as a second job, if I can.
That literally is what
happens in your brain
when you have a breakthrough.
That is literally where you
go when you're more creative.
I'm sure all of you have had
moments when you were on a run,
when you were just
spacing out during a walk,
when you were in the
shower, and suddenly you
just realize something.
And the reason it works is
because your executive mode,
the part in the
front of your brain
that takes care of
everything, that
gets you places on time,
that finishes projects,
it has to go quiet.
But it can't-- it doesn't just
go quiet if you tell it to, it
gets annoyed if you do that.
So you have to fake it out.
You have to give it a goal.
We're going to
walk to the store.
Now the executive's happy.
We're going to
finish the dishes,
we're going to take a shower.
The executive's
like great, I have
something I'm going to finish.
Thank goodness, I'm so
happy this is the case.
And it's sort of-- but
it's kind of mindless.
You don't concentrate
hard on it.
OLIVIA FOX CABANE: Judah?
JUDAH POLLACK: Yes.
OLIVIA FOX CABANE:
If you're wondering
what we mean by "if you tell
the executive to go quiet,
it gets annoyed," how many
of you have tried meditation?
Right.
How many of you have
experienced the monkey mind?
Exactly, so you know
what we're talking about.
That's what happens when you
try to tell the executive
to go quiet.
You're welcome.
JUDAH POLLACK: And so--
but if you give it this
kind of mindless task, what
happens is power,
literally, power
reroutes from the executive
and goes to this genius lounge,
this default mode network.
And it's like the espresso
machine gets fired up,
and all the different
parts of the network
start drinking coffee.
And they start getting jazzed.
And the different parts
of this network, they
encompass so many various parts.
You have your own
personal memories.
You have your error prediction
and your future prediction.
You have your sense of
empathy, trying to figure out
how somebody else is feeling.
You have your own sense of
self, your metanarrative that's
moving through this.
You have your inferior
parietal lobes,
which is all the physical
sensation coming into you.
It goes on and on, the
sheer number of things
that this network is engaged in.
And what it does when
you're on some sort
of random little task, is it
starts mixing and matching
information.
It starts playing around, as
if you had a pile of LEGOs.
And it's just making all
these LEGOs together,
and then holding
them up and saying,
is this a brilliant idea?
Is this a brilliant idea?
Now, one of the keys to
this is that it's not
that the executive
plays no role.
As you saw in the
video, the geniuses
keep looking to the executive.
They're like, hey, we came up
with this, what do you think?
The executive is actually
saying yes or no.
And so at some point,
your geniuses come up
with something really good,
your executive says yes,
and that's when it enters
your level of awareness.
That's your aha moment.
Now, the science kind
of stops at the moment,
at how does your brain
determine what's a good idea
and what's not a good idea?
How does it know to wake you up?
We don't know yet,
but we do know
that this is what's happening.
And there are certain
things that we all
can do to capitalize on
this natural ability.
And the first one is plasticity.
So the reason I
showed you this video
was for a very specific reason.
I'll show it to you again.
Watch the defense.
[CHEERING AND YELLING ON VIDEO]
JUDAH POLLACK: The
defense just stands there.
They just look at the
quarterback, dumbfounded.
And the reason it works is
because what's happening
is not within their
realm of what's possible.
They don't notice it,
they don't expect it,
and so they can't
think of what to do.
He literally has the
ball and is walking
by seven people who could
tackle him at any moment,
and nobody moves because
they can't put it together.
That is what plasticity
allows us to do.
Brain plasticity is
our ability to build
new neural connections, to
understand new thoughts.
To give you an idea
of what plasticity is,
I want to show you this.
So this is a video by
Drew Berry, who does
amazing biological animations.
Highly recommend you go check
out his stuff, it's brilliant.
And here he's got
a single neuron.
And when you're watching
happen is the axon--
or, I mean, the stoma, or
the body, the big bulb there,
is what's sort of giving
out pulses of electricity.
There's new research
out, actually,
that it's not just the
body that does that,
but we don't even get
into that right now.
And we're moving along
to the dendrites.
These are the parts of the
brain that just branch out
like a river, and the
parts of the neurons
that just go out
and out and out.
And along them, you
have these little heads,
these little buds.
And on the top of
these buds, that's
where you have neurotransmitter
receptors, the places that
accept things like serotonin,
dopamine, neuro epinephrine.
The thing you need to realize is
this is not a static situation.
What you're seeing
right here is you're
watching a new
neurotransmitter receptor being
born for the first time, and
now, all of a sudden, there
is a new way for the neurons
to connect to one another.
And because there's
a new way for them
to connect to one
another, there's
a new thought that can happen.
Because that's one of the
most important things for you
to understand.
Your thoughts are not
chemical, your thoughts
are not electrical, your
thoughts are structural.
Your brain is literally building
new neurotransmitter receptors
every millisecond.
And in doing that,
you have the ability
to build new connections, and
having the ability to build
new connections gives you the
ability to have a new thought.
Basically, messenger RNA sends
a message to transfer RNA.
This is transfer RNA.
Look at the very top.
You see the ACC?
Those are amino acids.
This little factory stacks amino
acids one on top of the other,
and then when it's
done, it cuts them off.
And then this amazing,
magical thing happens.
The protein folds.
I'm sure you've heard of this.
In this case, and what
we're talking about,
these proteins fold and form
new neurotransmitter receptors.
So it's our ability to do
that that makes us plastic.
Your brain is structural.
You're building the
actual infrastructure
to have a new thought.
And so one of the first
things that you all
have to get better at, that
everyone has to get better at,
is getting more
practiced at doing this.
So people who tell
themselves, I'm not creative,
I don't think of these things,
I'm not that sort of person--
that is equivalent to sitting
on the couch for two years
and then somebody tells
you to do 10 push ups
and you can't, and you say
I guess I'm just weak now.
I'm just forever out of
shape, it's hopeless.
Now, you know
that's not the case.
You know you just need
to work out and get fit.
The same is true
about your own ability
to have a breakthrough,
to be creative.
We have become neuro
couch potatoes.
We do the same
things over and over,
and when we do the same
we don't challenge our brains
to build new neurotransmitter
receptors, which means we
can't build a new thought.
And that's why we get stuck.
That's why many of us end up
like the defense on that team.
Something new has happened,
and we can't process it,
we don't know what it
is, and it walks by us.
This is what it's like when
you lack neuroplasticity,
but you're trying to come
up with a new thought.
And there are
tools that can help
you actually get to something
that's more like this.
And so that's what this is
really about, is the tools.
It's about changing your
neurons from this to this.
You want all those branches,
you want all that connectivity.
That's what you're looking for.
What do you think this is?
Don't be shy, you've
no way of knowing,
so just shout stuff out.
AUDIENCE: Paint?
JUDAH POLLACK: Paint.
AUDIENCE: Fabric?
JUDAH POLLACK: Fabric.
See that-- feel that push?
Feel that push?
That's like trying to do a push
up when you're out of shape.
AUDIENCE: Smoke.
JUDAH POLLACK: Smoke.
AUDIENCE: Colored liquid.
JUDAH POLLACK: Colored liquid.
AUDIENCE: Turbulence.
JUDAH POLLACK: Turbulence.
AUDIENCE: Mold.
JUDAH POLLACK: What was it?
JUDAH POLLACK: Mold.
So this is ink drops in water.
And you were getting there,
you are all in and around it.
But now that I've told you
it's ink drops in water,
you're looking at it
again and your brain
is actually forming a new
set of neural connections
to make that into a
memory, to understand
that that's what that is.
You've broken open
into a new space.
Exposing ourselves to things
we don't know, to things
we don't understand, to things
we don't see a lot, that
is literally one of the greatest
ways to create neuroplasticity.
This is one of our
favorites, Erik Weihenmayer--
eh?
OK, you'll let it go?
He has climbed the
seven tallest mountains
on all seven continents.
There's just one funny thing,
as if that weren't enough.
He's blind.
So how does he do this?
How does he possibly
climb this mountain?
Something called the brain port.
See this little thing?
He puts that on
his tongue, then it
is connected to
these glasses, where
you see a camera on the front.
The camera takes in
the light signals,
and it becomes
electrical impulses that
are signaled to his tongue.
The tongue signals
those into his brain.
Because the person who invented
this, Paul Bach-y-rita,
said we don't see with our
eyes, we see with our brains.
Our eyes just happen
to take in the light,
but if we can figure
out another way
to take in the light
signals, our brains
will figure out a way to
see because our brains are
so plastic.
Because we can create so many
new connections, and little
by little, he learned to read
the signals from his tongue,
and he could actually
start to see,
even though there was nothing
coming through his eyes.
Another story we love is a young
woman in China, 24-yeard-old,
walks into the
hospital, kind of dizzy.
They do they do a CAT scan,
she has no cerebellum.
She was born without one, it
was full of liquid in her head.
She shouldn't have been
able to ever walk, much less
hold down a job, function.
But the other parts
of her brain started
to take on these
other abilities.
Our ability to be plastic
is almost never ending,
it's astounding.
We just need to actually
work the muscle,
and it's incredibly important
that we work the muscle.
A number of things that
we like to suggest,
come to work one day dressed
completely differently than you
ever do.
If you're a dress down
sort of person, like I am,
wear a suit and a
tie, fancy shoes.
First of all, the fabric will
move against you differently,
and it will give different
physical impulses
to your brain, which goes right
into your default network.
The other thing
that will happen is
people will respond
to you differently.
You're going to get a whole
different set of information
from people as they react
in these different ways.
And you're going to-- you're
just going to take this all in.
If you're a woman and you tend
to wear heels and dresses,
wear pants and a
pair of sneakers,
or vice versa on both
the men and the women.
Just change it up.
Another one that I like to
do is borrow somebody else's
playlist, that you
don't know what it is,
and just listen
to it for the day.
Just the songs that come up,
the way they make you feel,
what you're
experiencing with it.
We like to talk about
eating things you ordinarily
never eat.
Because the brain
signals are new,
you have to sort of process
what is this new thing?
This one is really
difficult, especially
given the political
situation right now,
but read political magazines
you ordinarily wouldn't read,
listen to talk radio you
ordinarily wouldn't talk to.
It might not be worth it
from the stress level,
and we understand that.
But it's another
way of just taking
in totally different
information.
Or watch movies you
would never watch.
Read a book you
would never read.
Get into a conversation
with someone
you'd never get into
a conversation to,
and just take in things
that are brand new.
When you go to
home tonight, take
a completely different
route if you can,
and just notice what's new.
Notice what's different.
Change up your routine.
Routine is the
death of plasticity.
You're wanting to just change
it up and see what's going on,
see what you can
bring in that's new.
I suggest all of you go
and visit Olivia if you can
and hang out with her
chickens and her bees
because you probably
don't do that very often.
And watching chickens is
actually kind of fascinating.
They call it chicken TV,
and you can just watch them,
but they behave in a way
you just don't notice,
you just don't see.
This is one of the
reasons you feel
more alive when you go on
vacation, because everything's
new.
And it's popping in your brain.
When the plasticity's
going, you feel it.
It fundamentally feels
good and feels different.
Another piece about
this is new information.
You want to take in
things you ordinarily
would never hear about, would
never see, would never do.
So try a sport you've
never tried, if you're more
physically oriented.
Ride a dirt bike.
Go mountain biking in
Moab, go on a trapeze--
be careful, I once hurt
myself terribly on a trapeze--
but take in all of
these different pieces,
because the physical
reality that you engage in
is going straight into
your default network,
and it's causing all kinds
of new things to pop.
But one of the reasons new
information is so incredibly
important is because it's
this other element to the way
that our default network
works, and we couldn't get
into it in the animation because
it was a little too complex,
but here's what happens.
Right now, you're
paying attention to me,
or at least I hope you're
and you're creating
memories in your brain.
And what your
hippocampus does, which
is what's in charge of
creating your memories,
is it takes all this information
and kind of puts it on a shelf,
and it waits to encode it
as longer term memories.
And then when you're off task,
when you're not really focused,
your hippocampus starts
to form these memories.
Meanwhile, you're off task,
so your default network
is also activated.
All of a sudden,
your hippocampus
does a very strange thing.
It takes random shards
and combinations
of these new memories
and it throws them,
like little sparks, into
your default network.
So your default network has
all of this information,
kind of like building a fire,
and then your hippocampus
throws the new information
in as a spark to light it.
So if you don't have
new information,
your default network,
your genius lounge,
just keeps spinning
on the same stuff.
It can't really bust
through to something new.
This is one of the
reasons very often
people who have
breakthroughs do their work
and then also have
some kind of hobby.
They have something else
they're really interested in
because that brings in
the new information.
That starts getting
things to bang
into each other in
new and novel ways,
in ways they weren't expecting.
So if all you do
is work, it's going
to be that much harder to have
that creative breakthrough
because you want to bring
that new information
in from somewhere else, from
something else, something
that's just different.
So how do you access it?
How do you actually
get into this mode?
OLIVIA FOX CABANE: Judah, if
I can step in for a second.
JUDAH POLLACK: Please.
OLIVIA FOX CABANE:
One of the ways
that we like to explain the
importance of plasticity
is if you look at
a martial artist.
So, say someone who is doing
an actual, useful martial arts,
like Brazilian jiu jitsu
and not some sissy practice
like karate.
You know that one--
I'm slightly biased-- you know
that there's one thing that is
the actual techniques-- what are
the moves, how can you roll--
and then something
completely different,
which is the physical
conditioning.
Plasticity is like doing cardio.
The plasticity on its own
won't-- isn't necessarily
the exact--
the exercise for plasticity
isn't necessarily the one
that'll lead you
to breakthrough.
Just like having a lot
more physical power
won't necessarily get
you to win on the mat.
I was regularly tied into knots
by my sensei, who was a shrimp.
Was about this big.
He could take on an 85
kilo guy without a problem.
But it's part of what will make
you better at the final result.
So the same way you
do cardio, regardless
of which end sport
you're going to do,
you want to get
better at plasticity,
because it's a good conditioning
to then use the breakthrough
tools.
Am I making any sense?
Yeah.
Please, please, please,
jump in, ask questions.
If you have
objections, raise them.
We really encourage the
debate in the moment.
There might or might not
be a Q&A period at the end,
so take advantage of it.
All yours.
JUDAH POLLACK: Objections?
AUDIENCE: Can you
repeat his question?
JUDAH POLLACK: Yes.
So the question was what are
the good contrasts in terms
of your work versus a hobby?
What are good ways to
create that differentiation
so that you get the most
out of the new information
to get the novel ideas.
And-- so there are two things
going on in your question.
Some of the things you suggested
go to what we have up here,
which is accessing.
So sleep, walking,
these are less hobbies,
although I like to think
of sleep as a hobby.
That's a great idea.
But these are less hobbies
and they're more ways
to access your network.
They're way-- they're
doorways into that sort
of mindless state, where
you're sort of floating
and you're not paying too
much attention to anything.
Then there's an actual
hobby, where you are focused.
So actual hobbies
can be anything.
Woodworking is great.
Watching movies is
great, or reading books.
Cooking, rock climbing, cycling.
It doesn't really matter,
collecting stamps.
OLIVIA FOX CABANE:
[CLEARS THROAT]
JUDAH POLLACK: Yes?
OLIVIA FOX CABANE:
I have an objection.
Personally, I've always found
that things that are wordless
are better for the
mind wandering.
So for example, when
you watch a movie, even
if it's a movie that
you know really well,
the verbal center--
processing center of your
brain is still active.
Whereas if you're rock
climbing, if you're--
well, if you're
beekeeping, you're
usually berating yourself
for the many mistakes
you've just done--
but if you're climbing, if
you're running without music,
in my experience that
just works better,
because of the
lack of distraction
from the verbal processor.
JUDAH POLLACK: And
just to be clear,
there's no absolute
answers to these things.
You find your own way.
Because I would turn
around and say my mind
will wander very often
when I'm reading.
You ever read the same
paragraph over and over,
and then you're like oh, I keep
reading the same paragraph?
It's because you've
mind wandered.
So for some people, absolutely,
the verbal processor completely
gets in the way.
For other people, it just
sort of-- it can shut down.
So you're just looking
for what works for you
and what interests
you, because you don't
want it to be a force.
You want it to be something
that you actually like.
But the key is to give it time.
Give yourself time
to truly do it.
Give yourself time to
truly learn about it.
Because that's going to create
new and different information
that can then
combine with the work
you're doing to show you
novel, new possibilities.
Does that makes sense?
AUDIENCE: It does, thank you.
JUDAH POLLACK: You've got it.
And so, to continue-- oh, yes?
Please.
AUDIENCE: How does
meditation fit into all this?
JUDAH POLLACK: Oh, the
meditation question.
Excellent question.
I'll start, then you'll--
OLIVIA FOX CABANE: We
debated in the book
just how deep to get
into this, because--
JUDAH POLLACK: [LAUGH]
OLIVIA FOX CABANE:
No, seriously, there
are some dark sides to many
practices of meditation,
and so--
JUDAH POLLACK: So, meditation.
Ironically, you would think
meditation would put you
into that kind of state.
However, the majority
of meditation practice
actually quiet your
default network.
They actually make
it happen less.
One of the reasons is because
there's a part of your default
network that is all about
your meta awareness,
so it's all about what
do I think about myself?
You ever get caught in a
loop, thinking bad thoughts
about yourself?
That's your default network.
This is one of the
reasons depression
and creativity get
connected very often
because it's the same
network in your brain
responsible for both.
And meditation
quiets that network,
it can help you with depression.
So at the same time--
JUDAH POLLACK: Caveat warning.
JUDAH POLLACK:
--at the same time,
the default network
gets strengthened when
you're in a meditative state.
Literally, your gray
matter thickens.
OLIVIA FOX CABANE: Oh,
that's not where I was going.
JUDAH POLLACK:
Where are you going?
Please, please.
OLIVIA FOX CABANE: OK.
Judah and I have slightly
different approaches to-- well,
actually a lot of things,
but meditation in particular.
I'm the ruthlessly
pragmatic one in this duo.
So the way I look at meditation
is really like a toolbox,
or like a cheeseboard
or something.
The same way you wouldn't
use a hammer or a wrench
for the same
purpose, the same way
that personally,
I would recommend
using metta or vipassana
for the same purpose.
It really is the same way
where you talk about yoga.
It runs the gamut
from the 180 degrees
Celsius bikram rooms to
the hold the Mountain Pose
for three days kind of things.
Meditation, for me,
is the same way.
It's a toolbox.
So it really depends as to
what you're going after.
And you could be going
for emotional healing,
you could be going
for internal insight.
The way I tend to
see it, and there's
a lot of push back, this is just
one personal way of seeing it,
from easiest to
hardest is how much
sedatives you give
your monkey mind.
So TM, transcendental
meditation,
is a really nice entry
point into meditation
because it gives you what is
direct drugs for the monkey
mind, which is words.
So you get a mantra to
repeat, and in some traditions
it's considered
sacred and personal,
in some other
scientific studies,
it seems that pretty much
any sound that you repeat
can have the same effect.
But you get something
mental to focus on.
In various traditions of
vipassana, of insight,
you can focus on any object
in meditation, be it the--
a candle.
Your breath is usually
the most portable.
For a lot of people like
probably us in this room,
that's the nice, dry,
comfortable work of the mind.
And for a lot of
us, it's easier--
probably most of us in
Silicon Valley-- it's
easier to work on something
like insight meditation
because it's all in the mind.
It's a lot easier than the
messy, ugly, uncomfortable work
of the heart, which is the
realm of practices like metta,
loving kindness.
Tonglen, compassion.
Please don't get into
tonglen until you're
damn sure you're ready.
You're taking on the sufferings
of the rest of the world.
So if you want to
grow your heart,
you're going to use one tool.
If you want to grow
your plasticity,
you're going to want
to grow another.
The caveat I was
going into is there
are some forms of meditation
that I personally would not
recommend to beginners.
Zen is a good example.
People have been known to go
into schizophrenic episodes
on zen retreats.
How many of you have ever
gone on a silent retreat?
Please raise your hands.
OK.
For those of you who haven't,
please, please, please, please,
please consider going on one.
There are very few
experience of which
I would say without the
slightest second of hesitation
it's a life changing experience.
I would say that about
going on a silent retreat.
Those of you have gone, has
this been your experience?
Please feel free
to say no if not.
AUDIENCE: That's the way to go.
OLIVIA FOX CABANE: OK.
Now, that's an answer,
it's really good.
I hate silent retreats.
But it's kind of like--
meditation is training
for your mind.
It's like going to
the gym for your mind.
And usually by 2/3 of the way
into a meditation retreat,
you are certain that
you are failing,
the meditation
practice is failing,
this whole idea is stupid, and
you want to go home anyway.
And there is a certain
arc that you will
see your own mind go through.
The caveat that I
was going into is
that meditation can, in
certain circumstances,
help you through depression.
It can also
precipitate depression.
So as with any other tool, it's
useful to have good mentors,
teachers, or-- and they can be
in the form of books, humans,
it doesn't matter--
but who can guide
you along the way,
so you get sure that you don't
get stuck into a vicious cycle
that through meditation can
actually worsen depression.
Am I making sense, does anyone
have any questions, comments,
objections, please?
AUDIENCE: So what you're
saying [INAUDIBLE].
OLIVIA FOX CABANE: Yeah
meditation can in some cases
worsen depression, especially
if you're on retreat.
AUDIENCE: Yes, but it can
also get you out of it.
OLIVIA FOX CABANE: It can
There's a fantastic--
AUDIENCE: The [INAUDIBLE].
If it gets you into it and
then gets you out of it,
that balances the nice result.
OLIVIA FOX CABANE:
Here you're saying it
as if it were a single thing.
It's not.
You've got first, a bazillion
different traditions
of meditation, and
each experience you
have is going to be different.
There is a book that I recommend
very, very, very highly.
It's called "The Mindful
Way Through Depression."
It is one of the best books
I've seen on those two things,
but there's--
if you're just
starting to meditation,
get out of your mind
and into your life,
but the classic, the favoritest,
would be "Wherever You Go,
There You Are."
And those are all really
good introductions as
to seeing where your
mind can take you,
and learning to
drop below the mind,
learning to-- just
because something
is in your head doesn't mean
it has any validity whatsoever.
Yeah?
OK.
All yours.
JUDAH POLLACK: OK.
One last thing out
there I was just saying
is that it has been
shown to increase
the gray matter in
your default network,
and increase the connections.
And so what can happen is,
even though you may not go
into a mind-wandering
state of creativity while
in the meditative state,
when you come out,
you're kind of
charged and ready--
OLIVIA FOX CABANE: Now--
JUDAH POLLACK: --to
be stronger with it.
OLIVIA FOX CABANE: Talk
about the gyrification,
it makes you smarter.
JUDAH POLLACK: Sorry?
OLIVIA FOX CABANE: Talk about
the gyrification, that it
makes you stronger and smarter.
It increases the
folds in certain parts
of your gray matter, and I
pronounce it gyrification,
you might not.
JUDAH POLLACK: That's what threw
me off, but it doesn't matter.
Go.
OLIVIA FOX CABANE: We
have slight differences
in pronunciation,
as you can see.
And then-- the
complexity of the folding
in that part of your
brain is directly related
to your rapidity in
processing information.
So it literally can
make you smarter.
You're going to explain
it a lot better.
JUDAH POLLACK: That sounds good.
And so the more--
the more your neurons
are closer to each other,
the more they're wrapped
around each other,
the more surface area they
can get into contact with--
kind of the way your genes
are wrapped up in a ball--
the more chances there are
for the new connections.
So that's why it can
improve what's going on.
Again, your brain is structural.
So as you as you strengthen
the structure of your brain,
you strengthen your ability
to have these breakthroughs.
And so while meditation is
ordinarily not an access point,
it's a strengthening point, so
it's a plasticity strengthening
point.
The access points are
things like taking naps.
Salvador Dali discovered the
power of the hypnogogic state,
when you're just falling
asleep and you're
in that liminal
in-between space.
And other people have
discovered the hypnopompic,
which is when you're
just coming out of it.
When somebody says sleep
on it, that's a real thing.
Because when you go to
sleep, your default network
starts working on things and
right as you're waking up,
it tends to tell you things.
And so in the book we talk
about Adam Cheyer, who's
one of the co-founders of Siri.
And this is just a
general practice of his.
He goes to sleep, focuses on an
idea, specific problem he has,
and that's using
his executive to say
this is what we're
working on, and then
he just allows this
default network
to do its thing at night.
And then when he wakes
up, he kind of checks.
He's like, what did it tell me?
And it usually told him
something, he writes it down.
He then gets up,
goes to his desk,
goes back to his
executive network,
and starts working it out.
And you see this
happen all the time.
Einstein famously went
to his friend one day
after 10 years in 1905, working
on his theories about light
and simultanaeity
in time, and he's
like, you know what, I give up.
I'm done.
And he went home,
and he went to sleep,
and he wakes up, and voila.
He comes back to
see his friend, he's
like, I have it,
thank you so much.
But here's the thing
about breakthroughs.
That wasn't it.
He then spends six weeks
with his executive function
writing it all out,
getting it all straight.
So there's this
constant back and forth,
there's this interplay between
the two that is so important.
And so when you
access this mode,
you have to also remember to
use your executive to focus you
on the issue at hand.
To say OK, this is what
I want to think about,
this is what I'm going to do.
Now I'm going to go take a walk.
Now I'm going to go take a nap.
Now I'm going to go for a swim.
Now I'm just going to
sit in this hammock
and let myself just
sort of wander off.
Or I'm going to pick up this
book, but I'm not going to be--
I'm not going to be focused
on like finishing the chapter.
I'm just going to let
myself read the book
and see if I kind of wander off,
see if something just comes out
of it.
Or, if you're very
good at meditating,
sit down for a 10,
20, 30 minutes sit.
And then when you
come out of it say,
I now want to think about this.
Go for a walk, because
you've just sort of
done an awesome workout
for your default network.
And it's sort of
primed and ready to go.
And then you have to let go and
let it sort of do its thing.
One of the issues with accessing
it is because of the world
we live in.
We live in a world where we
are on task all the time.
And one of the
interesting things
is Douglas Rushkoff, an author,
has this fascinating concept
where he said we have all this
technology, all these machines,
and yet we're busier than ever.
Weren't they supposed to
make our lives easier?
Why is this?
And his theory is that we have
internalized machine time.
We actually operate at the pace
and rate of the machines that
are supposed to be helping us.
And so we answer emails
at all times of the night.
We answer phone calls whenever.
We're on constantly.
And the problem with
being on constantly
is you never access
your default mode.
You never access
the genius lounge,
and therefore you
never give yourself
the chance to have
the brilliant ideas,
to have the great breakthrough.
The interesting thing is that
to have a true breakthrough,
we need to pull back and
step into human time.
We need to slow down, we need
to allow that pace to happen.
We operate better when
we do that, we just
forget, get overwhelmed,
and then go, go, go, go, go.
And it's not helpful.
So part of the
challenge with accessing
this is allowing
yourself to slow down,
is allowing yourself to
re-enter human time to do things
like walk and nap and rest.
Awe.
The experience of awe
is a wonderful way
to access your network.
You just look up at
a picture like this,
and the sheer immensity of
it all, and how small we are,
and we're aware of something
larger than ourselves.
And the research shows we just--
we open up into a
whole different space.
And we open up our brains
into a whole different space.
And different connections occur.
Different parts of our brain
start talking, and we just--
we're open to this.
And this also
makes us slow down.
You ever see anybody
just running along
the rim of the Grand Canyon?
When you come upon
something that produces awe,
you slow down.
When you walk up to a
Redwood, you slow down,
and you just kind of sit
there and say, my god.
You don't even have
to believe in God,
and that kind of comes
out of your mouth
because we're just aware of this
larger entity in the universe.
And so go and look out, even
just looking out across the bay
will do this.
So look out at the ocean, or
go up to the top of Mount Tam,
and just look.
The grand vistas will
ignite this in us,
will bring it out of us.
I want to talk a little
bit about constraints
and the concept of wabi
sabi because constraints
can be incredibly
helpful when it
comes to accessing this sort
of breakthrough ability.
Wabi sabi is this
Japanese design concept
where you start with the flaw.
The flaw is your zero
point, and you integrate it.
The flaw is not to
be gotten rid of.
The flaw's not a
problem, the flaw
actually directs the way in
which you're going to design.
And I love what street
artists do with this stuff.
So a crack in the wall
becomes Spiderman's web,
and a railing becomes fun
for Calvin and Hobbes.
And this guy is
breaking out of jail.
In this one they've turned the
breaking down of the plaster
on the outside wall
into a factory,
and it's the smoke coming
out of the smokestack.
This kid's having a good time.
And here we've got camels
making their way in a caravan.
And all of this is
from they saw a flaw.
Something was
wrong, and then they
used that to define how they
were going to create the art.
And so the question becomes
what's the flaw in your system?
What's your biggest obstacle?
If you start from that
point, and not say,
how do I get rid of it, but
say how is this my start point,
it creates all kinds of creative
abilities, creative capacities.
The flaw acts as sort
of the access point
into your default network.
And so one way you can do this,
and you can do this with teams
as well, is you build
a constraint box.
And we've found that
to be really useful.
We did this with Genentech
a little bit ago,
and it was very helpful.
Because they were talking
about how annoying
the federal regulations were.
So we spun it around,
and we were like,
we'll let's talk about
what are the constraints.
And what you do you start
to lay out the constraints.
Right, Dave is a
serious problem for me.
So is the FDA.
So is the cash flow, and
it's really not sexy,
what we're talking about.
It's going to be hard to get
anybody interested in it.
So these are some
of your constraints.
And you just get
a sense of them.
You lay them out so they
don't get overwhelming.
The next thing you
do is you start
talking about your assumptions.
Because very often you're
assuming things that
aren't right, that aren't true.
And if you don't write
them down and look at them,
they're just going to
stymie you the whole way.
So, no one's going
to listen, Angela
hates this idea, 18
months to see results.
It's cost prohibitive, you
just lay it all out there.
You look at it, and you
question all these assumptions.
Are they really constraints
or are they just things
that you've assumed?
They're conversations
you haven't had.
And the reason you
do it in this form
is because what
happens in the end
is this becomes
your solution space.
You've now defined
where you can be free.
You've defined the space where
your default network can now
try any number of things.
So as opposed to these things
hemming you in and locking you
in, they turn
around and free you.
Because now you
know that you don't
have to bother looking
at those things,
you have to bother beating
your head against them,
and now you've got this
space that's opened up.
And that freedom is what
allows the default network
to start to truly function.
And so especially when
you do this with a team,
it's amazing what
comes out and why.
You start finding out that
there are all these assumptions
on the table that
have stopped people
from getting interested in
things that weren't even
correct in the first place.
And little by little,
people start to realize,
oh, but you know what we can
do, oh you know what we can do,
and once you're in that space,
now your default network
is live and functioning.
And so this is one of
the ways the constraints
can act as a really powerful
tool to get you into this.
Roman Mars of 99% Visible,
a really fun podcast,
he has a great TED talk
talking about flags.
And he's like, you should
be able to draw your flag
on a three by five note card.
And everybody thinks it's
ridiculous and crazy,
but he's like that's one of the
best constraints you can have,
because it's going to
drive you to making
a really excellent flag.
And you can use that kind
of constraint and anything.
Can you express it in a
three by five note card?
Well then you probably don't
understand it well enough.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Why do you call
it the default network?
JUDAH POLLACK: Why do I
call it the default network?
I don't, I'm quoting.
When you're on task and doing
something, it goes more quiet.
When you're off task, your
brain defaults to this network.
It just-- this is where
it goes every time.
So that's why it's called
the default mode network.
And one of the funny
pieces is that the person
who discovered it,
Dr. Marcus Raichle--
how'd I do?
OK, we'll leave it alone.
The way he figured
it out was he was
noticing that when he
had people in fMRIs,
and told them to just hang on a
second, just wait, don't think
about anything, we have
to do something over here,
all of a sudden all
this activity showed up
in their brains.
And everyone was like,
oh it's just static,
it's just noise, whatever.
And then one day, he
walks out of a meeting,
he's wandering down a hall,
and it just showed up.
The idea showed up, and
so what happened was
he was thinking about this,
and then when he was
off task, wandering down
a hall, his default network,
the brain defaulted to it,
and then it gave him an answer
to a question he'd been asking.
Which is what's up with
all this noise in the fMRI.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
JUDAH POLLACK: Yes.
It's-- it's because it's this--
it's this place where all
these different pieces
are coming together and
talking to each other.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JUDAH POLLACK: And--
right, and they're
just sort of putting
things together.
So we've discovered it.
It truly is the engine
of our creativity.
That's what we've been
starting to find out.
And so these are all just ways
you can actually get into it
and use it, focus
yourself on it.
One of the things that--
we talked about this a lot
in the beginning
of the book, can we
give a kitchen recipe for this?
Can we say one cup of
butter, two eggs, some sugar,
some chocolate chips, voila,
you'll have a breakthrough.
And the answer is no.
It's a non-linear process;
it's an emergent process.
And so you have to give
yourself time with it.
But what we're teaching you
is that you can actually
set conditions to make
it far more likely
that it will happen.
Switching, I want to
make a slight switch now
to associative thinking,
which in the end
is truly what your
default network is doing.
And so I'm going to show you
something that will both raise
your plasticity but also kind of
get into associative thinking.
Somebody left their
Go Pro on the ground
and a squirrel picked it up.
So, I don't know about
you, but I'd never
seen anything like that.
That is literally a squirrel's
eye view of the world.
And so it does a
couple of things.
One, it forces this
growth of plasticity
because you're like oh, my
god, it's like it's this big,
and it's moving on branches
you could never move on,
and it's moving so
quickly through the tree.
I used to move through
trees very slowly.
And all of this is
new and new and new.
And then at the same time,
it adds to this piece
that we call
associative thinking.
So all the media about
artificial intelligence
and how it's going to replace
human beings and yadda yadda
yadda.
Most people who are
aware know that there's
this big leap between where
AI is at the moment, which
is amazingly good at the
pattern recognition and the data
crunching, and the
intuitive, inferential leaps
between ideas.
And that's something that
human beings are still
particularly good at.
And it's the association
of the different ideas,
what's sometimes known
as abductive reasoning.
To have a little
bit of data here
and then to get a whole
theory out of it here.
And this is what the default
mode network gives us.
It is what takes
different pieces of data
and puts them together into
a whole new conceptions,
whole new theories.
And so having experiences that
are completely different--
this gets at the hobby idea--
brings in the ability to
create these associations
you might not ordinarily see.
So in the same way in
the 1970s San Francis--
California, there was
a huge drought, people
drained their swimming
pools, they just
looked like empty holes.
But a bunch of kids were
like, these are skateparks.
That's something that comes up
from the default mode network.
Or the skateboarding
kid who wants
to be able to keep
practicing in winter,
so he creates a snowboard,
and invents snowboarding.
Or the Army has got
Lexan, a hard plastic,
that is used in
their windshields
of their helicopters.
And these windshields
are getting scratched up
like nobody's business
in the deserts of Iraq
and Afghanistan,
and in the training
at Fort Irwin in California.
And they're spending
tens of millions
of dollars replacing
these Lexan, very
scratchable windshields.
And lo and behold, there are
these two Army Reserve National
Reserve guardmen who are
helicopter mechanics and NASCAR
fans.
And they're like,
well, you know,
NASCAR uses the same Lexan
on their windshields,
but they put these thin
mylar sheets on top of them
before every race.
They're called tearaways,
and at the end of the race,
they pull them off.
The mylar took all the
hits and scratches,
and the windshield's fine.
But why don't we just put
them on the army helicopters?
They took it from one
place, moved it to another,
they associated it, saved
the Army tens of millions
of dollars because the
windshield's lifespan doubled
and tripled.
But it was already there.
They associated it; they
moved it to another realm.
And very often this
is how we end up
seeing innovation happen.
How many of you know of
Thomas Edison's electric pen?
Exactly.
He's not very proud of it
either, wasn't very successful.
Ended up in the window of a
pawn shop, downtown New York.
Who should be walking by but
this guy, Samuel O'Reilly.
Samuel O'Reilly
takes a look at it,
and he's a pretty clever guy.
And he's like, I think I
could change this around.
Samuel O'Reilly invents
modern tattooing
by changing the electric pen.
Moving things in their context,
from one context to another,
is very often where these
innovative ideas come from.
It's the association.
And it's your default
network that's
making those associations,
that's connecting,
that's inferring, that's
intuiting between vastly
different things.
So there is a young
meteorologist--
whose name I wrote
down, I can't remember.
It's over here somewhere.
I'll get it at the end.
But he's up in the Arctic
in the early 1900s.
And something just strikes
him, that the ice kind of looks
like jigsaw puzzle pieces.
And that's it.
He just notices that.
It's interesting to him.
A year later, he's
looking at a globe.
He's like, huh, you
know, the continents kind
of look like jigsaw pieces.
I wonder if they
were ever together.
And he goes, and he checks out
the rocks along South America
and along Africa,
and he checks out
some of the floor
and fauna, and he's
like I think these
things drifted.
He invented the concept
of continental drift,
which eventually took
us to plate tectonics.
A meteorologist
making a breakthrough
in geology because
of an association
he made by looking at
the ice in the Arctic.
This is very often how it
works, this idea of curiosity,
of noticing the way different
things come together.
And it's the default
network, it's mindlessly
staring out at the
ice and being like,
huh, they look like
jigsaw puzzles.
And then mindlessly staring
at a globe and being like,
oh, the jigsaw puzzles kind of
remind me of the continents.
This is where these
things come together,
and that's what I'm saying.
It's important to
allow ourselves
to be off task, because we
don't allow ourselves to access
that network otherwise.
So I want you to
imagine that gravity
stops working at 10 PM and
then starts working again
at 7:00 AM.
How is our entire
culture different?
Start throwing things out,
whatever you can come up with.
Are there nets over every house?
Are houses designed
more like boats, where
everything is locked down?
Are children sort of tied to
their beds before 7:00 PM?
How do teenagers play
around with this, how
do they rebel,
given this, how do
they get in trouble given this?
How do people throw
nighttime parties?
What does Burning Man look like?
You could just keep asking
yourself this, over and over
again, and it seems
silly, but really it's
coming out of the tradition
of thought experiments,
which Einstein uses.
Just playing out what is
possible in the universe,
what might occur.
And one last one I'll show
you, the very end is, so this--
whoops.
Yeah, this is the
world's most boring video
unless you put
this music over it.
Now all of a sudden
there's tension.
And you're probably wondering,
did I put a shark in it?
Is there-- is it
going to pop up?
Are you going to see
that fin come up?
Or is it just the
mouth going to pop up?
I don't have those
skills, this is just
like the world's
most boring clouds
out the window of an airplane.
But we put the music on,
and suddenly your brain's
creating a whole universe.
You can do this with any
movie scene in the universe.
All right, I'll end the tension.
You can literally take
any movie scene you want,
add music to it, and
watch how it changes.
Watch what happens.
I had one group where
somebody shouted out
last scene of "Casablanca,"
and somebody shouted out
"We Are The Champions" by Queen.
And they thought they had me.
They thought they'd nailed me.
And I was a little
nervous, I was
like, I don't know how
this is going to go.
So we go to YouTube, we
bring up the "Casablanca,"
put it on mute.
We bring up "We
Are The Champions,"
turn it on, start the two
of them, we start watching.
And it's shocking how
it starts to line up.
And as the plane
starts to take off
and Elsa's is being taken away,
the music is crescendoing,
and Freddie Mercury is
going, "We are the champ--"
and you like, oh my
god, it's so moving.
And it's totally random, and--
play this game.
Literally, play this game.
And it sounds silly,
but it's amazing
how it sets you
up for then being
able to connect to things
you ordinarily would never
think would work.
And that's where those
breakthroughs come from.
So there's play involved,
there's a craft involved,
there's practice involved.
There are these tools, it's--
but it's not something in
theory, it's something you do.
It's a way you are in the world.
And so you have the ability.
You have the brain for this.
You have all the parts
for it, everybody does.
We just have to use
them, practice with them,
and get comfortable with them.
And that's why we
wrote the book.
See, that's nicer.
Thank you, everybody.
[APPLAUSE]